season two of the mandalorian ended in
triumphant fashion
with fan service galore and just like
season one
the second batch of mando episodes
offered up a ton of fun star wars easter
eggs
for fans to find here are a few you may
have missed
to kick off chapter 16 the rescue the
team assembles to retrieve grogu from
the clutches of moff gideon
here's the plan they'll board the
imperial light cruiser gideon is keeping
grogu
imprisoned on locate him potentially
liberate the darksaber
and escape before the imperial dark
troopers are activated
of course for this to work they require
a vessel capable of deceiving the
cruiser's deck crew
their ship of choice is the lambda class
imperial shuttle escorting dr pershing
this particular brand of shuttle has a
long history in star wars
first appearing in return of the jedi as
darth vader's personal transport
also in that film the endor strike team
steals one to use as camouflage to evade
imperial forces
on their way to the forest moon's
surface apparently this is a perfect
ship to use if you want to cause some
trouble for the empire
near the beginning of chapter 16 boba
fett and mando meets up with costco
reefs
and bogotan crees to ask for their help
after some tension and a brief scuffle
costco warns that if boba doesn't back
off he'll quote
be talking through the window of a
bacter tank that certainly doesn't sound
good
but what exactly is a bacter tank it's
mentioned in the season 2 finale is a
call back to both the empire strikes
back
and the clone wars as baghdad tanks
appear in both as their name suggests
baghdad tanks are well tanks that hold
people who have been gravely injured the
tube-like vessels contain gallons upon
gallons of bacter
a fluid that promotes accelerated
healing in the star wars cannon there
are public made use of bacter tanks to
patch up injured fighters
and clone troopers could receive back to
tank treatment at medical stations
luke skywalker himself who makes a
triumphant return via cgi in this
episode
got submerged in a back to tank at
huff's echo base after his run in with a
wamper and the empire strikes back
as seen in rogue one even darth vader
knew the benefits of bacter tanks
as he kept one in his castle for times
when he didn't want to be bogged
down by the heavy armor he was forced to
wear after being sliced up and burned
alive
in revenge of the sith even though
bogatan cares to some degree about
rescuing grogu
she makes it clear that she's after one
thing and one thing only the darksaber
mando's mission to rescue the young
force user proved the perfect chance for
bo katan to get the artifact back
and in turn liberate mandalore but her
plan couldn't have gotten more awry
in his attempt to free grogu from his
holding cell mando
finds himself locked in a duel against
gideon and his dark saber
miraculously the bounty hunter manages
to defeat the imperial remnant leader
with the help of his best scar spear
making him the new owner of the
unconventional lightsaber
according to mandalorian tradition as
gideon mentions
the only way to become the rightful
owner of the dark saber is to defeat its
current wielder in battle
thus adding to its legend while it may
appear that moth gideon simply wanted to
create discord among the team
he's actually telling the truth
according to what we've learned about
mandalorian traditions and the clone
wars and star wars rebels
therefore should bogotan weigh her
options and value mandalore's future
over her allies ship with mando
despite the fact that it'd rather give
it away it's entirely likely the two
will square off down the line
then again if he just handed it over it
wouldn't be the first time that's
happened
on rebels sabine wren just gives a dark
saber to boca tan
with the approval of her clan without so
much as a scuffle
in the after credit stinger we traveled
to tatooine once more
now revisiting the former palace of the
villainous gangster jabba the hutt
that's currently under the control of a
recognizable face
it appears that as a result of his death
in return of the jedi
jabba's majordomo bid fortuna asserted
himself as the head of his criminal
empire
and indulged in the perks that came with
it the throne
the dancers the works he's also
noticeably gained a few pounds
while he doesn't have a very rich
backstory bipfortuner is a classic
background
alien from the original star wars
trilogy he was jabba's right hand man
for years
even as long ago as the time of the
phantom menace where he appeared
alongside his employer
following the destruction of jabba's
sail barge many assumed this scheming
twilight perished with it
but the mandalorian proved that wasn't
the case instead bib fortuna met his end
at the barrel of boba fett's blaster
and the bounty hunter will presumably
take over his duties
as an underworld kingpin in the book of
boba fett a spin-off arriving on disney
plus in december 2021
after the first few shots have fired
outside bib's quarters a body rolls down
the stairs
bib then waves one of his gamorian
guards forward instructing him to
investigate the disturbance
he's speaking her tease the language of
jabba's species
and the episode's subtitles don't
provide translation so it's tough to
know everything that bib told the
gomorian
however if you listen closely you'll
hear that what bib says before the
guards run off
is mcclunky
star wars fans will recall that in the
disney plus version of a new hope
greedo the bounty hunter who's long been
the subject of the who shot first debate
involving han solo says a word that
sounds exactly like
mcclunky just before he shoots at han
vanity fair reported in 2019 that this
edition was done
at the behest of george lucas himself
mcclunky is also the same phrase that
the pod racer sabolba uses when he
threatens young anakin
skywalker and the phantom menace
subtitles for that film reveal that
mcclunkey
translates from her tease to it will be
the end of you
so unlike the mysterious dank ferric the
untranslated expletive of choice in the
mandalorian
we actually know what mcclunky means
[Music]
the seventh installment of the
mandalorian second season chapter 15 the
believer
was a grogu free-throw ride on a new
tropical planet as
always there were plenty of cool easter
eggs tucked away for fans to find
here are a few you may have missed
chapter 15
opens on the return of migs mayfeld the
mercenary and former imperial
sharpshooter who double crossed
mando in season 1. when we catch up with
him this time around he's now under new
republic custody and working at a
scrapyard
note the old ads repurposed once again
as cranes
just like in chapter 11. mayfeld's luck
turns around on marshall karen dune
arrives to acquire his services and
knowledge to imperial protocols
as part of the plan to locate moff
gideon not looking to turn down the
chance to redeem himself
he departs the planet with her and
mando's crew passing by a familiar
background alien on his way out
before he meets with dune mayfeld walks
past a wolf-like being known as a hask
which is a fairly new breed to the star
wars franchise first appearing on screen
in 2015's
the force awakens we know from books and
other media that their culture is
limited in regards to their technology
but once they figured out space travel
many chose to take on odd jobs across
the galaxy
to help satiate their desire for chaos
and fans of star wars resistance
know that a good number of hask joined
the ranks of quarren pirate trajin gore
during the new republic era
now aboard boba fett ship slave 1
mayfeld has briefed on a situation
concerning grogu's abduction and mando's
plan to get him back
the only issue is for the ex-imperial to
gain access to moth gideon's coordinates
he needs to use an internal imperial
terminal
thus he points the crew in the direction
of the planet's morak to find one
however this won't be an easy task as a
good portion of the empire's remaining
forces
occupies and mines the planet for a
volatile fuel known as rhidonium
which has a long history in the star
wars universe first appearing in the
clone wars episode missing in action
rhydonium is depicted as an incredibly
dangerous and highly explosive chemical
as a result it's frequently used as a
weapon of war just as often as it powers
military-grade transports
since its debut rhydonium has made its
presence felt all over star wars media
from rebels to the poe dameron centric
comic book series and as the mandalorian
proved when it does make the odd
appearance
it's best to look for cover as soon as
possible
while scoping out a way to infiltrate
the empire's base on morak
mando and his group determined that the
easiest way to sneak behind enemy lines
is for two of them to take over an
imperial fuel
transport and then disguise themselves
as the drivers initially
cara dune is more than prepared to join
mayfeld for this phase of their plan
but he explains to her that she can't do
so since the installation has the
technology
to detect the genetic code of those on
new republic records
also he name drops a subdivision of the
imperial war machine
that appears to have dissolved with it
the imperial security bureau or isb as
mayfield refers to it was a branch of
the imperial intelligence network that
specialized in law enforcement during
the empire's heyday fans of rebels
should instantly recognize the acronym
as kallus made a name for himself as an
isp officer before defecting to the
rebel course
and those familiar with clone wars know
that former republic navy admiral wolf
yoloran
who also appeared very briefly in a new
hope became the commissioner of the isb
shortly after the empire situated itself
as a galaxy's new governmental system
as mando and his team arrive on morak
they quickly realized that getting to
the
imperial terminal will be anything but
easy the planet is crawling with
imperial loyalists
and plenty of pirates looking to
interrupt their operation by any means
necessary
but still they go ahead with their plan
to infiltrate the local installation
of course the empire didn't just send
the run-of-the-mill stormtroopers
to guard the mine and fuel refineries
and instead diversified their ranks with
some other recognizable trooper classes
from different eras of the star wars
universe
first and foremost the design of the
rydonium transport team's armor is
reminiscent of imperial hover tank
pilots
from 2016's rogue one digging deeper
into the spin-off film's plethora of
trooper designs you'll notice that they
also encounter a large number of
imperial shoretroopers nothing like the
ones present during the battle of scarif
additionally kara and fenix shan's
sniping put a new hope-style death star
gunners in their crosshairs
driving the point home that the backbone
of this galaxy-wide regime isn't as
disjointed as many believe
having successfully infiltrated the
imperial base with only a mild amount of
trouble
from the locals mando and mayfield keep
their eyes peeled for the terminal and
find it rather swiftly however they run
into mayfeld's former commanding officer
valen hesse who commends them for their
successful delivery of the rhydonium
not realizing their true intentions in
an apparent nod to the 1999 comedy
office space
mayfeld and mando attempt to elude hess
with an excuse about filling out tps
reports but it doesn't work
uh you apparently didn't put one of the
new cover sheets on your tps reports
oh yeah i'm sorry about that i i forgot
mayfield also fibs and claims armando is
hard of hearing
following an incident on tanab tanab is
first mentioned on screen in return of
the jedi
when lando explains to han that a
maneuver he pulled off during a battle
on the planet got him promoted to
general
valen hesse invites mando and mayfeld to
join him for a drink and some
reminiscing over the empire's finest
moments including the short-lived
operation cinder
made famous by the 2017 star wars
battlefront 2 video game
after the death of emperor palpatine and
the destruction of the 2nd dexter
imperial sentinels directed the
remaining forces to begin carrying out a
plan
known as a contingency one aspect of it
dubbed operation cinder was devised by
the seth lord personally
it effectively destroyed planets across
the galaxy that were once under imperial
control
large climate disrupting satellites
placed above specific imperial worlds
annihilated their ecology and residence
ensuring that the empire and its enemies
didn't continue in the event of
palpatine's death
it's a pretty twisted concept but it's
fairly on brand for a regime of bred
from the dark side
the sixth episode of the mandalorian
second season chapter 14 the tragedy was
an action-packed installment sure to
please boba fett fans
and as always there were plenty of
easter eggs tucked away in the margins
teased at the beginning of the
mandalorian second season chapter 14
finally brought boba fett back to the
forefront
of the star wars universe in grand
fashion he not only reclaimed his armor
but also took the fight to a platoon of
hapless stormtroopers
reminding everyone why he's considered
the most ruthless bounty hunter
in the galaxy still while this wasn't a
specially big return for boba fett
one couldn't help but notice how the
memory of his father jango fett
dominated much of his screen time this
is evident first when mando questions
him on his mandalorian heritage
boba fett replies i'm a simple man
making his way to the galaxy like my
father before me
fans of attack of the clones know that
this is reminiscent of a conversation
that jango had with obi-wan
where he said i'm just a simple man
trying to make my way in the universe
additionally boba mentions that much
like his ship slave 1
his famed arm is set as a hand-me-down
once belonging to his father
fett also explains to mando that
contrary to popular belief
django didn't steal it rather he earned
it years ago during his days as a
foundling
boba says his father django even served
during the mandalorian civil wars
an event alluded to now and again in the
clone wars animated series
the conflict was a reason for the divide
between sateen crees of mandalore and
governor pree vizsler
of concordia after mando recovers his
best scar spear
boba fett says he wants mando to take a
look at something then presses a spot on
his armor just above his wrist
a sequence of texts written in the
mandalorian language flashes into the
air
boba explains that's his chain code
which has been encoded into the armor
for 25 years
the audio description on disney plus
calls it a lineage tree
as boba points out the code mentions
both him and his father
but what about the other lines star wars
fans online made quick work of
translating the chain code into english
it's incomplete but some of it makes
sense from left to right it reads
foundling took into the year the concord
dawn
mentor just father fett boba fett
but what does all that mean first
mentioned in the clone wars and first
appearing in rebels
concord dawn as an outer rim territories
planet led by fen rao
mandalorian protectors ruled concord
dawn in the age of the empire
on concord dawn the empire crossed paths
with rao and fellow mandalorian warrior
sabine wren who gave the darksaber to
boca tan before it somehow ended up in
moth gideon's hands
additionally concord dorm was the home
planet of reiko hardine
a bounty hunter known as the marksman of
concord dawn who once tried to
assassinate
obi-wan in an episode of the clone wars
concord dawn is also allegedly where
jango fett himself was born
according to the canon reference book
star wars the complete visual dictionary
new addition
the mentor jazz part of the lineage tree
is likely a reference to justin mariel
a mandalorian warrior also born on
concord dawn
and an important figure to the fed
family in legends cannon
mariel first appeared in the comic
django fete open seasons in 2002
initially serving as a journeyman
protector a low-level cop essentially
mario wound up killing a corrupt
high-ranking officer driven by his
unshakeable morals
for this he was exiled from concord dawn
and eventually joined the mandalorians
mariel later rose in the ranks to become
the sole leader of the mandalorian
people
he established a mandalorian honor code
resulting in tension from the new
mandalorian group
and the death watch splinter terrorist
group led by the vicious tor vizsla
when war erupted maria headed back to
concord dawn where he saved and orphaned
django fed from a death watch attack
mariel became django's adoptive father
and mentor but was killed six years
later
by vizsla django later avenged monreal's
death
then rose to become the new leader of
the mandalorian people
there were a few minor easter eggs
hidden in chapter 14 worth mentioning
boba fett says that the appearance of
maf gideon's light cruiser isn't a spice
dream
a reference to spice the most popular
illicit substance in the star wars
universe
first mentioned way back in a new hope
the drug is a staple in star wars
stories
and the pivotal part of solo was even
set in a spice mine
blue butterfly-like insects similar to
the one flying near grogu
appeared on endor on the battlefront
video game series and
a slightly different blue species
appeared in the clone wars the e-web
heavy repeating blaster used by the
stormtroopers in this episode before it
was crushed by a raiders of the lost ark
style runaway boulder
first appeared in the empire strikes
back at the battle of huff
and finally while dark troopers first
appeared in the 1995 game star wars dark
forces
their designers depicted in the
mandalorian sure call to mind tony
stark's iron man armor
especially while in flight this makes
sense of course considering iron man
director
and happy hogan portrayer john favreau
is the showrunner for the mandalorian
the fifth episode of the mandalorian
second season revealed that baby yoda
is really baby grogu and introduced in
live-action one of star wars most
fearsome jedi warriors
the episode also featured some fun
easter eggs for fans to find
shortly after the impressive live-action
debut of ahsoka tano
chapter 13 jumps to mando and grogu
arriving on corvus to meet with the
tegruta force user about potentially
teaching the little one
they promptly land and make their way to
a nearby settlement where they are
welcomed by barren grungy streets
with sparse inhabitants among them is an
ad series smelter droid first
introduced in the original star wars
trilogy the most notable of this run of
droid went by the moniker 88
and appeared on the big screen for the
first and only time in return of the
jedi it didn't hold the spotlight for
very long that's its biggest claim to
fame as being the one responsible for
torturing a gunk droid
at jabba's palace over the years however
this brand of droid has become a
frequent background presence
across other forms of star wars media
including the animated series the clone
wars and the galaxy's edge novels
mando was barely in town five minutes
before the magistrate summons him to
speak with her
she gets right to the point offering
mando a spear made out of pure besca if
he kills ahsoka
while he doesn't necessarily accept the
job formally he does secure from his
wannabe employer a set of coordinates
to find the jedi he and his foundling
set off into the mangled wilderness
but little do they know something is
watching them high above their heads
resting on a tree branch
sits an owl-like creature known as a
convoy rebels and clone wars fans
surely recognize the significance of
these birds as they're prevalent
throughout ahsoka's journey in the star
wars canon
and represent the purity of the light
side of the force dave filoni who wrote
and directed chapter 13
has gone on record saying that these
creatures are also observers
and protectors and the one present in
the mandalorian just before ahsoka
arrives to defend herself against mando
fits that description perfectly
asamando eventually comes to an
agreement that benefits them both
if he helps her displace the magistrate
and free her settlement
she'll take grogu under her wing and
hone his forced powers
according to mando the magistrate is
always flanked by two hk87 assassin
droids
which fans of the star wars the old
republic mmo will surely recognize as
bad news hunter killer droids first
arrived via the 2003 star wars knights
of the old republic video game
and were characterized as highly
efficient assassins known and feared for
their stealth
various models took center stage
depending on the story
the most notable being darth revan's
personally constructed hk47 others
appeared all over old republic era media
until it was stricken from the universe
back in 2012 following disney's purchase
of the star wars ip
their unsuccessful attempt to stop mando
and ahsoka also marks their first
live-action appearance in the franchise
once the jedi and the mandalorian make
it back to the village they get started
right away and infiltrate at stick walls
and in true star wars fashion a massive
firefight ensues from there
severely outnumbered ahsoka has no
choice but to utilize a stealth approach
to take down her enemies
at one point in the fight she begins
traversing the back alleys in an effort
to box her opponents in
leading them to carefully sweep the area
and apparently frustrating the local
tuca population
this lovable yet dangerous feline has
become a staple of star wars media over
the past few years
dating back to their earliest
appearances on the clone wars the most
well-known sub-species of tuca is a lot
cat a frequent face in rebels
and a handful of doctor apha comics as
well as in other various books and shows
well we've been out here for hours and
all i've seen are these stinking loaf
cats
additionally this isn't their debut in
the mandalorian either as one variety of
tuka popped up in the season one episode
is sanctuary scaring grogu
unsurprisingly the magistrate can't hold
her own for very long against ahsoka
tano
and ultimately loses their duel the jedi
knocks the spear from her opponent's
hands holding a lightsaber up to her
neck as a form of intimidation
hoping to get the information out of her
that she desires she demands her foe to
reveal the location
of grand admiral thrawn non-rebels
viewers might be a bit lost here but for
those who spent plenty of time with the
ghost crew right up until the series
finale this is exactly the question
they've waited years to find out the
answer to
a holdover from the non-canon star wars
expanded universe
grand admiral thrawn burst on the rebel
scene at the beginning of season 3.
during the liberation of lothal at the
end of season 4
thrawn and ezra bridger were shot into
hyperspace by a group of purgil
and haven't appeared in any star wars
media since ahsoka and sabine wren
set out to find them shortly after but
as evidenced by the mandalorians reveal
the search goes on at the end of chapter
13
ahsoka doesn't necessarily hold up her
end of the deal once again refusing to
train grogu
but she does give mando a push in the
right direction just before he and his
foundling
board the razer crest for their next
adventure she advises that they set out
for the planet typhon
where the ruins of an ancient jedi
temple reside there grogu can sit on a
seeing stone
and decide between letting his force
abilities go or continuing his long
dormant training he might even be able
to connect with one of the few jedi
left roaming the stars typhon is not
well known to the star wars universe
featured only in a novel a few comics
and a game before its small screen debut
on the mandalorian
but its importance to the overall
history of the galaxy is immense
located in the deep core and shrouded in
mystery typhon is one of the planets
considered the birthplace of the jedi
religion
in fact it serves prominently as the
starting realm for the jedi
in the mmo rpg star wars the old
republic
[Music]
episode 4 of the mandalorian second
season chapter 12
the siege is once again stuffed with fun
easter eggs for fans to find
in the opening moments of the siege
mando and the child make way for navarro
so that the razor crests can receive
some much needed repairs before the big
trip to corvus
navarro has undergone some serious
changes since the last time mando was
here but the cedia criminal elements are
getting navarro's reputation
remain festering in the shadows one such
example is a small band of aqualis
thieves who took up residence in the
amara's former forge
navarro's new marshal cara dune makes
quick work of the aqualish
a recurring species in the star wars
universe familiar to fans of a new hope
especially
one particularly short-tempered aqualish
named ponderbaba
famously tried to pick a fight with luke
skywalker in the mos
eisley cantina before obi-wan intervened
grief karger and cara dune insists that
mando leaves a child at the newly
established school on navarro
but not before passing a statue of ig-11
the assassin droid who sacrificed itself
for our heroes in season 1
at the school which was a cantina when
we last saw it in the season 1 finale
i'm surprised to see this place is still
standing the child gets the chance to
learn about the current geographic
makeup of the galaxy
or he would at least if he wasn't
fixated on those macaron-like turquoise
cookies
at any rate during the lesson the
protocol droid instructor name-dropped
some relevant locations in the star wars
universe
the most notable detail the droid
teacher touches on is that the new
republic capitol has shifted from the
iconic locale
of coruscant to sandra the birthplace of
mon mothma
and ben solo aka kylo ren in the same
lesson the droid also points to an
important area of the galaxy called the
akadizi maelstrom
which hosted one of solo a star wars
story's most intense sequences
this dangerous region houses the more
cluster the home of the beast that
nearly swallows the millennium falcon
hole
drawing han solo and his crew's perilous
attempts to make the famed kessel run
they of course make it in less than 12
parsecs as long as you roll down
speaking of solo the red skinned alien
who plans to track her on the razor
crest is a mimbanis
a species first introduced in the
standalone prequel flick
with the child presumably safe at school
and the razor crest in for a tune-up
grief mando and cara head back to
grief's office to talk business
the moment they walk in the door they're
greeted by mithril who now lives a life
of servitude to make up for getting on
grief's bad side this is the same
character mando took the bounty on and
frozen carbonite in the mandalorians
premier episode despite having thawed
some time ago
mithril complains of a very familiar
side effect that comes with prolonged
carbon freezing
grief makes sure to let mithral know
that he has no qualms about sticking him
back on ice
should he not follow his directions to
which the blue alien remarks that he
preferred not to
and that he still can't see out of his
left eye this refers back to return of
the jedi in which han solo's release
from carbonite established the existence
of hibernation
sickness an ailment that presents itself
as temporary blindness
depending on the length of one's
imprisonment
the team wastes little time departing
navarro for the outlying imperial base
only installations upper level kera
mando and grief
assess their situation and review the
plan while mithral stands in ore at what
will become their one-way ticket after
sabotage base
a trexler marauder this vehicle which
appears to be a variation of an imperial
troop transport
has popped up in a few star wars
projects lately including star wars
rebels
but it took over four decades to get the
vehicle in live action
this particular people move as routes go
way back to the toy stores of 1978 where
the imperial troop transport
arrived as a part of kenner's star wars
action figure line so mithril's
excitement at finding a quote
mint trexler marauder is likely a nod to
the vehicle's toy store origins
surprisingly the mission to ridden the
viral of imperial presence goes off
without a hitch the crew manages to make
a fairly clean getaway
but not before they uncover a disturbing
secret about why the empire is so
interested in the child by the looks of
things the imperial remnant is going all
in
trying to perfect a way to clone a
force-sensitive being a hologram message
from dr pershing
explains the empire's dire need for the
child's blood if they're to keep this
mysterious program going he also
mentions a child's m count
likely referring to the amount of
midichlorians in his body that
contribute to his proficiency
in the force midi chlorians have
remained one of the most controversial
parts of the star wars universe
since their debut in the phantom menace
and fans haven't heard them discussed in
the franchise for quite some time
so what does this all mean this
fledgling imperial cloning program could
connect to the miraculously alive
emperor palpatine
and his tanks full of snoke clones the
rise of skywalker established that
palpatine spent years biding his time on
hexagonal
in rapidly decaying bodies attempting to
find the path to immortality through
cloning
the remnant members of his empire could
have been hard at work
trying to create a new more powerful
form for their leader during the event
of the mandalorian
considering how strong yoda and the
child species is and the force
and the length of their natural lifespan
there's no better candidate for a sith
lord who's trying to rule the galaxy for
all time with absolute power
but there's also another possibility
at the very end of the siege maf gideon
admires a whole room full of large black
stormtrooper-like figures
what are those supposed to be the audio
description on disney plus has the
answer
calling them immobilized the dark
troopers dark troopers first popped up
in the 1995 first person shooter game at
star wars dark forces where it's implied
that they're droids and the word
immobilized that does suggest that
gideon and his technician
are tending to a fleet of powered down
butts but dark troopers have also been
described as cyborgs and other star wars
media
meaning gideon could be preparing exo
suits for future for sensitive clone
bodies to occupy
dark troopers also appear in the dark
empire series of comics as elite
stormtroopers who have received forced
training so this could also be the
destiny gideon has in mind for the
clones
after all if they're just droids why
wouldn't gideon have already deployed
them perhaps he's waiting for a batch of
powerful force users to bring the suits
to life
and that's the whole point of dr
pershing's mysterious cloning project
whatever they turn out to be they're
probably bad news
mando had better be ready
[Music]
the third episode of the mandalorian's
second season chapter 11 the heiress was
a seafaring and stormtrooper zapping
good time with a fair amount of easter
eggs and callbacks
tucked away for fans to find the heiress
brought mando and his little green
friend to the never before seen watery
moon of trask
completing their mission to deliver frog
lady and her eggs back to her husband
credited here as frogman after a very
bumpy landing and an assist from a crane
machine that might just be a repurposed
imperial walker
we get a closer look at the residents of
trask both the quarren and the mon
calamari species joined the star wars
universe in return of the jedi
although they appeared in very different
places the quarren hung out with jabba
the hutt
while the film introduced the mon
calamari as key members of the rebellion
during the battle of endor the most
famous among them is the legendary
admiral akbar who remained a part of the
faction
until he died in the last jedi
additionally a season 4
arc of the clone wars put their conflict
on their home world of mon calal front
and center
plus rogue one also bolstered the mon
calamari standing in the rebellion ranks
with the introduction of admiral raddus
for both species the heiress isn't their
first appearance in the mandalorian
in the opening scene of the series
premiere a quarren was seen being sliced
in half by a door
grief kaga also offered mando a mon
calamari bounty in episode 3.
plus in the years mando finally uses the
mon calamari money kaga gave him
way back in the very first episode after
chartering a ship to go find more
mandalorians mando and the child are
betrayed by their quarrency captain
thankfully they're rescued in short
order from a new creature known as a
mamacore by a group of blue and grey
clad mandalorians
we know from the clone wars that these
are the night owls led by fan favorite
bokeh tan crease bokeh tan is played by
battlestar galactica's katie sakhoff
for the first time in live action and
she's hieris from the title
and nod to her past as the ruler of
mandalore bo katana arrived in the star
wars universe during the fourth season
of the clone wars with sakhoff also
voicing her
as death watch leader pre vizsla's
right-hand woman free vissler by the way
was voiced by mandalorian showrunner
john favreau
we know from the season one finale of
the mandalorian that mando was rescued
by death watch members as a child with
pre-vizzlers later demise at the hands
of darth maul
bogatan and a group of mandalorians
split off from the faction
and formed the mandalore resistance
playing an integral role in the siege of
mandalore during the clone wars season
seven
following the fall of the galactic
empire bokeh tan's exploits were
shrouded in relative mystery
as their story drops off after a brief
appearance in rebels
however it appears that the mandalorian
will rectify that
finally giving audiences the answers a
desire about her whereabouts and motives
in a post-imperial world
in the mandalorian season one finale maf
gideon used an ancient mandalorian
darksaber to cut through the wreckage of
his downed tie fighter to escape
since that moment viewers have wondered
how exactly this top-ranking imperial
officer
wound up with the artifact before its
re-emergence however
bokeh town was the last person shown
wielding it in star wars rebels after
fellow mandalorian sabine wren handed it
over to her any specifics detailing how
she lost it however have yet to come to
light
there is something i need if i am to
rule mandalore something that was once
mine
the aries went a long way in solving
this mystery through a bit of key
dialogue from bogotan
the hints to her previously untold star
wars story after she and her crew fight
their way to the bridge of an imperial
shuttle
bogotan interrogates the head officer
played by titus weliver the third actor
from hbo's deadwood to appear this
season
following timothy elephant and w.l brown
bokeh turn doesn't get any information
out of him before he takes his own life
but she does allude to some kind of
shared history between herself and
gideon
asking the officer to take her to him
without actually naming him
hopefully the show will expand more on
how the weapon slipped from her hands
into gideon's at some point
after her rebels cameo after
successfully hijacking an imperial
gozanti cruisership
a model first spotted in the phantom
menace mando departs to continue his
mission of delivering the child to its
people
but not before asking his fellow
mandalorian where he can find the jedi
she claimed to know
grade 4 for his aid bokeh tan tells him
to travel to the city of kaladin to the
forest planet of corvus
a new location for the star wars
universe so who is this jedi on corvus
another animated favorite ahsoka tano
the debut of anakin skywalker's former
padawan and live action
has been a long time coming with
speculation over rosario dawson's
casting as ahsoka running rampant for
months
and the circumstances surrounding her
imminent arrival couldn't be more
satisfying for die-hard star wars fans
you should have seen him in person
anakin skywalker
he was my master having initially
squared off as enemies
bogutan and ahsoka allied during the
siege of mandalore
as detailed on clone wars seventh season
once the jedi disbanded and order 66
went into full effect
leading ahsoka to go into hiding the
status of their coalition grew murky
but it seemed that they retained some
method of contact throughout the
galactic civil war
and in the midst of the empire's
collapse also much like bogota
ahsoka's adventures continued through
rebels where she took up the codename
fulcrum and became a secret rebel
operative
episode two of the second season of the
disney plus hits the mandalorian
was as eccentric as anything in the star
wars universe
and that includes plenty of tasty hidden
easter eggs for fans to spot
after returning from the successful
crate dragon hunt the mandalorian
returns to mos
eisley in chapter 10 the passenger to
meet with pele motto he reports back and
lets her know that the supposed
mandalorian frequenting mos
pelgo was just a man in mandalorian
armor but she reassures him that she can
put him in contact with someone who can
lead him to his people
first she introduces him to dr mandible
a giant bug-like creature
whose brief screen time carries with it
a couple of meanings
mandelball appears to be a member of the
killick species first introduced in the
darkness trilogy of books by troy
denning
a killik that may or may not be dr
mandible also appeared in episode 5 of
season 1 of the mandalorian
sitting at the cantina bar it's also
worth noting that filmmaker peyton reed
best known for the ant-man movies
directed the passenger
thus the inclusion of this ant-inspired
character seems a not-so-subtle nod to
the director's
marvel cinematic universe contributions
when mando first gets back to moses
eisley after a long
strenuous walk across the desert his
first stop is at the cantina where he
finds motto in the middle of a
high-stakes card game against doctor
mandible
this scene doesn't last long and their
game isn't the focus by any means
but the cards in mato's hands point to
one of the star wars universe's favorite
pastimes a good old-fashioned game of
sabacc so back is a staple of star wars
appearing in everything from books tv
shows video games and obviously a few of
the movies
it's mentioned now and again throughout
the skywalker saga even popping up in
the background of the force awakens
but his most notable appearance came in
2018's solo a star wars story
in the film a young lando carissian
cheats a young han solo out of a game
but the smuggler later gets his future
ally back by using his techniques
against him to steal a win
walking away with the millennium falcon
turning back to the mandalorian here's a
neat detail
motto's unbeatable winning hand in the
passenger is known as an idiot's array
and it's the same winning hand lando had
in a star wars rebels episode
of the same name not so fast
it appears i have an idiots array
just before departing for trask mando
and the child wait inside pelimoto's
hangar for their passenger to arrive
as a token of their appreciation they
leave her with a portion of the kratos
dragon meat they secured in the previous
episode which he cooks up rather
peculiarly
a treadwell droid holds up the cut of
meat to the flames of a stationary pod
racer engine to roast it a reference to
a real life star wars eatery located at
disney's galaxy's edge theme park
the restaurant in question is ronzo
roastus a neat little place with a menu
including something for everyone
well ronzo roasters doesn't have any
crate dragon steaks for sale one of its
more decorative elements
draws a neat parallel to this
mandalorian scene at the heart of the
diner you can watch droids cook food
beneath a podracer engine
in the same fashion as motto's droid
even though it's all for show at the
amusement park
it's nice to see this method of food
preparation make its way into star wars
canon proper
mando and the child's journey with their
passenger the frog lady
and her containers of eggs becomes a bit
complicated since they can't utilize
hyperspace travel for the sake of her
unborn children
instead they have to make the journey to
the planet trask at sublight
meaning that anyone looking for mando
will have a much easier time finding him
that includes the new republic's x-wing
patrols who press the bounty hunter
relentlessly for information
about his ship and his shady dealings
we're out here sweeping for imperial
holdouts one pilot in particular likely
stood out to season star wars fans from
the moment he arrived on screen the
mastermind behind both the clone wars
and star wars rebels and an occasional
mandalorian director dave filoni
makes a brief appearance in the
passenger in a reprisal of his season 1
role as trapper wolf
the character made his franchise debut
in chapter 6 the prisoner
in which he alongside fellow directors
debra chao and rick famous
destroy ransar maok's space hunger
following the escape of new republic
prisoner quinn
following their crash landing in the
razor crest the mandalorian the child
and the frog lady are left to survive in
the bitter cold
of an unnamed ice planet fed up with
mando's sluggishness and repairing the
ship
the frog lady wanders off into the snowy
labyrinth and finds a hot spring for
herself and her ex
concerned for their safety mando tries
to get the frog lady and her precious
cargo out of the cave
and his hunch is right in a scene akin
to something from ridley scott's alien
or john carpenter's the thing
the child unintentionally awakens a den
of spider-like creatures
known as the krichner the crick now have
a long storied history in the star wars
universe
first realized in legendary concept
artists ralph mcquarries the empire
strikes back sketches
and initially known as knobby white
spiders while they never appeared in
that film
the krikner eventually made their spine
tingling entrance during star wars
rebels second season
in the episode the mystery of chopper
base they later appeared in a handful of
other installments of the series but
their introduction on the mandalorian is
their first in live-action
and for those with arachnophobia
hopefully they'd last
in a similar fashion to the initial
batch of mandalorian episodes
season 2 appears equally as plentiful in
the easter egg department
right off the bat the season premiere
kicks off in jaron's journey to find the
remaining mandalorians hidden across the
galaxy he hopes that they can help him
relocate the child aka baby yoda to
wherever he came from
and by extension lead him to his family
as well however this won't be a
one-and-done task as a mandalorian sex
are notoriously difficult to locate
meaning the titular bounty hunter has to
ask around to locate his people
the first stop for mando is to meet up
with an absin a call back to a cantina
alien from 1977's a new hope
named gore koresh on a cd unnamed planet
there the two converse drawing some type
of combat sport involving two gamorians
squaring off with vibro axes inside
something resembling a boxing ring
these pig-faced aliens made their star
wars debut in 1983's return of the jedi
posing as guards for the gangster jabba
the hutt
with the underworld kingpin long gone
from the time of the mandalorian
it appears his former palace rogues are
doing their best to make ends meet
along them were a handful of weak way
which just so happens to be the same
race as mopel goes rather than bartender
who just so happens to be played by w.l
brown who played the bartender dan
doherty
on hbo's deadwood opposite timothy
oliphant who happens to play marshall
kobanth in this
episode of the mandalorian but we're
getting ahead of ourselves
after concluding his lesson cordial
meeting with koresh mando and his
foundling make their way to tatooine to
look for the supposed mandalorian
wandering the planet's sandy dunes of
course they can't get a good look around
the planet from the razor crest
so they enlist the hangar of peli motto
who first appeared in the mandalorian's
inaugural season
alongside her crew of pitroids but
they're not the only droids running amok
as a familiar face pops up to help mando
navigate tatooine's perilous terrain
motto sought the map of tatooine inside
an r5 astromech unit
that fans of a new hope likely
recognized immediately in a new hope
luke skywalker goes after purchase from
the jawas a new droid for the family
moisture farm and the red and white r5d4
was his first choice
sadly the little guy didn't get to go
off and have galaxy-wide adventures with
the future jedi thanks to a bad
motivator
so that spark went to the fan favorite
r2d2 it's good to see that motto could
fix him up
even if he's a bit sluggish for her
liking now take your time
seriously you just can't get good help
anymore
the vast majority of season 2's first
episode takes place on tatooine which is
one of the most important locations in
the star wars universe
koresha's lead sends mando to the off
the grid town of mos pelgo
but bookworms would recognize it by
another name freetown
chuck wendig's 2015 novel aftermath
introduced a village
describing it as a dirty sparsely
populated settlement
that wasn't for the faint of hut the
mandalorian season 2 premiere however
marks the first appearance of the
rundown community in any visual medium
additionally during a discussion with
the mandalorian about mos pelgo
pelimoto name drops some other
recognizable tatooine locals
first and foremost she mentions mos
eisley a wretched hive of scum and
villainy the house chao mum's catina and
played a pivotal role in both the new
hope and the mandalorian season 1.
mose esper the home of watto's junkyard
and the birthplace of anakin skywalker
received a nod too
thus rounding out tatooine's few major
settlements
upon arriving at the largely
unremarkable mos pelgo mando enters the
local cantina to speak with anyone who
can provide him with information
on the town's supposed mandalorian
resident fernando the result was pretty
disappointing
he didn't find one of his people but
rather kobanth
who was simply wearing the armor with no
ties to the creed
it doesn't take a deep knowledge of star
wars to recognize the gear as boba fett
although if you only watch the movies
and tv shows you'll have to do some
digging to learn about cobanth
vanth made his debut in the star wars
universe in the aforementioned aftermath
novel
the book details his journey pretty
vaguely running over the broad strokes
of him receiving the armor from the
jawas
and subsequently saving freetown from
marauders and tuscan raiders
thus earning the moniker the marshall
which is why the season 2 premiere bears
that name
the mandalorian certainly picks up the
slack putting van
front and center with a series of
flashbacks to supply a bit more detail
than the book could pull off
committed as ever to his beliefs mando
refuses to allow vans to keep the
mandalorian armor
since it technically doesn't belong to
him since both of them are rational men
they come to an agreement that will
service both parties
mando can have every last piece of armor
so long as he helps van to take down
once and for all the carnivorous beast
known as the krait dragon
that's ravaged most pelgo for years they
might not realize what they're dealing
with but long time star wars fans
instantly recognize the danger the two
were in
crate dragons are as old as star wars
itself first appearing in the background
of a new hope
after c-3po and r2d2 crashed land in the
middle of the dune sea a great dragon
skeleton sits in the sand way off in the
distance
obi-wan kenobi later even mimics what
many fans assumed to be a great dragon's
howl
to scare away some tuscan raiders
despite holding a constant menacing
presence across all forms of star wars
media
crate dragons live ones anyway are an
incredibly rare sight throughout the
canon
most of the time the story relegates
them to a fleeting mention
or a set piece used to fill in space
even though they're massive beasts with
highly valuable pearls in their bellies
in some non-canonical star wars media
it's said these pearls can even be used
to craft the lightsabers
after making their agreement the cop
vanta the mandalorian made their way
across the dune sea
in pursuit of the crate dragon such a
long stretch of sand and scorching heat
is impossible to trek on foot so the two
found alternative transportation
to reach their destination mando rides
off on the same speeder bike he borrowed
from pelimoto
but vanth pulls up in something quite
out of the ordinary his makeshift
vehicle sported two large flaps on the
front
covering a turbine set below them with a
seating area attached to the rear
this hodgepodge of components calls back
to the phantom menace's pod racers
sporting a similar look to young
anakin's model there's no way to confirm
if it came from his specifically
but the pieces undeniably came from
someone's pod racer which is a neat nod
to the prequels
with the krait dragon defeated kob van
keeps his word in return to mandalorian
armor set to ding jarin
the episode concludes with the two
parting ways as allies and the best
card-clad bounty hunter rides off into
the sunset with the child at his side
per usual the episode's story looked
complete there but there was one last
surprise left for the fans
by far the biggest easter egg of the
mandalorian season 2 debut
came in the form of the most fearsome
bounty hunter to ever live
the legendary boba fett of course played
by tim warren morrison
who also played boba's clone father
django in two of the prequels from the
moment of the mandalorian's conception
audiences have clamored for fed to make
his big comeback on the show at some
capacity
after all he and the series main
character are incredibly similar
visually
and they're in the same profession so a
crossover felt like a given
the previous season didn't do much to
satiate this subset of fans
but thankfully for them season 2 is
going all in
now at long last jango fett's clone son
is once again making his way to the
forefront of the star wars universe
and by the looks of things he's in no
mood to make friends
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one